[Music]
imagine towering Stone fortresses rising
up from the Misty Moors surrounded by
Lush Greenery and protected by armies
and knights this is the world of castles
icons of the Middle Ages I'm rich
Burnett from wandrium in this episode of
perspectives three experts uncover the
true story behind the rise and fall of
castles from their development to their
military and social roles and finally to
the inventions that ended their reign We
Begin now in England where the Norman
conquest of 1066 paved the way for the
rise of these imposing structures
William the Conqueror used castles right
from the outset to assert his authority
and create strong points in his new
kingdom
the earliest were Mott and Bailey
castles in which a wooden keep or
stronghold was set up on a mound or Mart
sometimes man-made an area around the
Mart known as the Bailey would be fenced
in with a stout Palisade and contained
Barracks Stables a whale a chapel
storehouses and the other necessities of
a Garrison
ideally a ditch or moat outside the
Palisade would create added difficulties
for potential attackers
no such wooden castles survive but
Britain still has several in which the
original wooden keep was later replaced
by a stone keep
at Cardiff Castle for example in the
grounds of a much lighter building
stands the circular mot with a strong
Stone Tower or Shell keep on top
the next stage in Castle design was the
square Stone keep
several built in the 1100s survive
including those at Dover Orford and the
Tower of London
the tower begun in 1070 is almost a cube
107 by 118 feet at the base and 90 feet
tall
as the historian Mark Morris says
construction on this scale had not been
witnessed in Britain since the time of
the Romans the Normans were well aware
of this and seemed to have been
deliberately styling themselves as new
Romans come a conquering in Imperial
Style
the walls of these Stone towers are
often 10 feet thick meaning that they
feel oddly smaller inside than they look
from outside
the benefit of course was that no Siege
engine could knock down a structure so
immensely strong
the armies of the day lacked explosives
to destroy them only by tunneling
beneath it was it sometimes possible to
provoke a cave-in that might partially
destroy such a keep
The Logical Next Step was to build an
outer wall or curtain wall around the
keep making it all the more difficult
for attackers even to approach it
this development is visible in many of
the Great fortifications of the 1200s
the Tower of London for example was made
safer and stronger by having the keep
enclosed by an outer wall during the
reign of King Henry III when a second
war outside that one was added by his
son Edward the first it became stronger
still
the tower is one of many places where
you can see the development of these
stages and where in general the outer
layers are more recent than the inner
the superiority of multiple defensive
layers led to the development of
concentric castles designed from the
outset to present attackers with a
succession of obstacles to overcome and
making it likely that any who broke
through the first ring would be
subjected to devastating fire from the
second
concentric castles also included
refinements such as Towers bulging out
from the line of the curtain wall so
that attackers would never find shelter
from Defenders fire
probably the greatest concentric castle
in Britain is it carefully in Wales it
was built not by the king but by an
extremely powerful Baron Gilbert declare
struggling in the 1270s to assert his
power against the Welsh Rebel Llewellyn
at Griffith
not only does it have a concentric
design it's further secured by sitting
in the midst of an artificial Lake
making it difficult even to approach a
Causeway across one of the two dams that
created the lake could be heavily
defended
by the time it was finished however
whales lie securely in English hands so
the castle was never put to the test
a distinctive aspect of carefully is
that one of its Towers stands at a
crooked angle far off the vertical
it was probably blown up during the
English Civil War
but we have no documentation to prove it
in any case carefully just a few miles
north of Cardiff is superb the historian
Patrick cormack describes it as
quite simply one of the greatest
buildings of the Middle Ages equally in
importance to any of Britain's major
Cathedrals there never was a more
triumphant assertion of power and
magnificence by any Noble subject
refinements of various kinds are also
apparent in concentric castle designs
because the Gatehouse was a potential
weak point with wooden gates more
vulnerable to battering rams than walls
they might be protected by being
approached over a drawbridge that could
be hoisted in times of danger
similarly a portcullis a thick iron
banded gate that descended from above
added strength to gateways
murder holes overhead through which hot
liquids rocks and fire could be thrown
down on attackers are common in these
gate houses though I've never found a
reference to Boiling oil being used
except in fiction
Edward the first was England's Castle
Builder par Excellence he Consolidated
his grip on Wales in the 1280s and 1290s
by building four massive ones Conway
carnarvon Harlock and beaumoris
they were built for strength to over ore
Welsh onlookers to assert Edward's claim
to the throne and to provide him with
places to live safely and comfortably
while he was in the area
his architect James of Saint George came
from Savoy the area of the western Alps
where France Italy and Switzerland meet
Edward honored him with high pay and
generous Estates
carnarvon's walls are made of different
colored banded Stones this is an echo of
the walls of Constantinople the
Byzantine Capital which Edward had
visited when he went on Crusade
he cited carnarvon at the place where
the Romans had established their local
headquarters sigontium
in both these ways Edward was not merely
building a stronghold he was also
implying a continuity between the old
Roman overlords and himself as the new
one
in the days when castles were useful to
the degree that they could be defended
it's worth asking how successful they
were in resisting sieges and
safeguarding their Defenders
the answer is that they worked well so
long as the Defenders were Resolute and
well LED and so long as they had
supplies of food and fresh water
poor leadership famine epidemics and
internal treason could all provoke
failure among Defenders
harlech for example garrisoned by only
37 men withstood an entire Welsh Army
besieging it in 1294.
harlech also held out for seven years in
the 1460s as a stronghold for the
lancastrian side in the wars of the
Roses though admittedly it wasn't under
continuous threat
when you visit harluk today you find it
about a mile Inland with the sea visible
in the middle distance across an open
plane
when it was built by contrast the castle
was actually on the coast and could be
resupplied by sea
in the late 12th century the Normans
came to Ireland and began to establish
their Mastery over the country Norman
armor Cavalry and law approved
formidable to the native Irish and soon
the Normans were building wooden
fortresses that would eventually become
the characteristic Norman Tower house
castles that would dominate the
landscape in Ireland over 3 000 such
Tower houses were built and many still
can be seen in Ireland today
perhaps the most famous is the tower
that was renovated and occupied in the
1920s by the great poet William Butler
Yates this Tower which Gates named Thor
Bali Lee or balili Tower is typical of
the castles of the first few centuries
of the Norman occupation
they would construct a stone keep of
usually three stories that could command
a view of the surrounding Countryside
the keep would have a single door
entrance strongly built and barricaded
and above that will be a slot called a
murder hole through which Stones boiling
water or hot oil could be cast down upon
potential Invaders
the ground floor will be reserved for
the soldiers and fighting men of the
local Lord the second and third floors
would be for the Lord and his family
eventually these simple structures would
be expanded as surrounding walls
additional towers and other
fortifications built up around them
trim Castle in County Mead was first
constructed in the 12th century and it's
the largest Norman castle in Ireland
with a three-story Tower with massive
walls that reach 11 feet thick
additional towers that project out from
the central tower and a huge curtain
wall with additional Towers projecting
outward
belonging first to the delacy family
then passing to the mortimers who were
Earls of March this was the castle where
Richard II stayed on his Ireland
expedition in 1399.
he left behind two boys as Wards of the
mortimers one of whom was Prince Hal the
Future King Henry V and Shakespeare's
mirror of all Christian Kings
as trim indicates these early Towers
soon expanded to become whole
communities with trading stalls craft
shops dairies workshops and families
occupying the grounds around the castle
during times of attack or Siege the
surrounding families would Retreat
within the walls a source of water was
essential either a well or spring or
river so the castle could survive a
prolonged Siege
the castles were simultaneously family
homes economic centers and Military
outposts
they were meant to impose power and
authority on the surrounding Countryside
to concentrate the Lord's power and to
provide a base of operations of plunder
and suppression on the native Irish
in the centuries following the Norman
Invasion hundreds of these castles were
built across the countryside on June 29
824 there was an elaborate marriage
conducted in the Royal Palace of aachen
Germany
the chapel in aachen had been
consecrated in 805 for Charlemagne the
First Holy Roman Emperor and ruler of
the largest territory in Europe since
the fall of the Roman Empire
the wedding was sponsored by Louis the
pious who had succeeded his father
Charlemagne as emperor of the land all
the great Nobles assembled in the Stone
Chapel lit with many candles and
everyone knew this Union would join two
powerful families with the blessing of
the emperor himself
the groom was Bernard of septimania a
region in southern France he was the
godson of Louis the pious himself and
everyone was sure he was destined for
great things in the Kingdom
his bride was named Duda like many women
of the time Duda was swept up in the
violence of the age but she set herself
apart with her writings which give us a
rare glimpse into the mind and emotions
of a carolingian woman things appeared
bright for the couple
shortly after the wedding Bernard was
appointed commander of the Spanish
border guarding the lands near his
ancestral home and septomania in 8 29
Bernard received another promotion he
was called back to aachen to serve as
Chamberlain to Louis the pious what if
Duda during this upwardly mobile time
for Bernard
her husband left her behind
Bernard left her in his castle at uzes
in southern France
let's look more closely at what this
meant for Duda and a deed for many noble
women of the Middle Ages who stayed in
their fortified castles while their men
spent much of their time at War
the local Warfare that dominated Europe
beginning in the 9th century caused
local Nobles to build private fortresses
that could guard their surrounding
Countryside from Invaders
first these forts were built on Mounds
surrounded by Timber and Earth but they
slowly developed into the massive stone
structures that we can see today
these fortifications consisted of Great
Walls surrounding Open Spaces where
Knights guarded the perimeter and into
which local villagers could flee when
attackers came
dudas castle and uzes has not survived
but from other examples we can recreate
her World Behind These Walls
the main household of the castle
consisted of a large public hall where
the residents family members retainers
and guests gathered around an Open
Hearth in the center of the room at meal
times great Trestle tables were erected
in the hall and servants brought
platters of food
Duda and her family sat at a raised
table along one side while her Knights
and retainers arranged themselves lower
along Trestle tables they ate with
knives and spoons forks weren't widely
used yet using trenches of bread to soak
up Savory juices
dogs scrounged around the hall hoping
for bits or bones from the table
at Noble tables the main element of the
diet was meat beef pork chicken and
other foul and when available they
enjoyed game Deer was favored though
they also enjoyed boar and wildfowl
the vegetables were mainly used for
flavoring leeks onions turnips and
garlic
perhaps ironically The Peasants diet was
healthier focusing on beans grains
vegetables and milk and cheese
Duda met with her Steward and other
officials to order the food and make
sure the accounts were kept in order
from these records we know the daily
ration for a person living in an
aristocratic household
typically included two to three pounds
of wheat bread two to three pounds of
meter fish and a gallon of Ale this
seems an astonishing amount even
allowing for exercise so I imagine the
records allow for some leftovers for
servants
as you could see by these numbers ale
was a significant part of the noble diet
Al is unhopped beer and is most often
brewed from barley malt but wheat and
oats are also used
ale was served at all meals to everyone
from children to adults
by the 9th century wine was becoming
popular particularly in France so we can
imagine that duda's household included
Vineyards and young wine found its way
to the noble table vitners were not yet
skilled at aging wine
when meals were over the hall remained a
meeting and Gathering Place sometimes
people played games like backgammon and
chess or played music and sang
since Duda was reputed to be a fine
musician we can imagine she spent time
cultivating this art
there were smaller private Chambers
Behind the hall where the Lord and Lady
slept in a grand bed surrounded by
curtains to provide some warmth and
privacy
Duda spent most of her life without
Bernard in these Chambers her company
focused on her ladies in Waiting who
joined her in spinning weaving sewing
and companionship
gunpowder came into the West in the
middle of a war as shifting population
and skills caused new ideas to emerge
of course change often occurs in war
when people think they're losing
this happened during the Hundred Years
War that raged between England and
France
this war that was fought between 1337
and 1453 became the final straw in a
century and a half that destroyed
medieval traditions and social contracts
as I look at this war please remember
that the events occurred to the drumbeat
of plague famine anger and fear
this War began as a traditional medieval
one about the bloodline of noble rulers
and who could claim the Loyalty of the
nobleman who owed the king's Allegiance
it began with a problem in the
succession to the throne of France
in 1328 the king in the long-ruling
French capissan Dynasty died without a
male heir
the nearest male relative was King
Edward III of England
son of a caprician King's Daughter
did this mean that Edward could rule
both England and France
the parliament of Paris essentially the
Supreme Court of France
didn't like this solution because it
would mean that French noblemen would be
ruled by an English king so the Nobles
in Parliament ruled that a woman could
not transmit the claim to the crown
therefore they declared Philip VI to be
king
he was a first cousin of the previous
ruler
at first Edward did not contest this
decision but he soon found reason to do
so the new French King wanted to claim
Supremacy over English lands in southern
France
during the 13th century the French Kings
had reduced English Holdings on the
continent but here at the beginning of
the 14th century Philip thought it was
time to finish off the English presence
Edward decided to solve the problem by
claiming all the lands of France as his
Birthright
they went to war
this was a long brutal war that changed
medieval warfare as well as dynastic
loyalties in 1346 The Dashing and bold
English king Edward III sailed across
the English Channel to land in France
we don't have exact numbers but
estimates suggest that Edward brought
some four thousand nights supported by
ten thousand longbowmen and surprisingly
to all Observers
he brought some soldiers carrying a new
weapon guns
these were small cast bronze or iron
tubes strapped to wooden frames
Edward didn't entrust these weapons to
soldiers but to Specialists who
understood the new technology
these weapons consisted of a tube sealed
on one end like a reed in Latin Canon
and the name stuck
the Gunners placed their powder at the
closed end near a narrow hole to place
the fire to ignite the powder then they
inserted a projectile in the open end
sometimes they shot an arrow later a
lead or iron ball or even a stone the
explosion of the charge expelled the
projectile with a huge sound and if the
metal of the gun was weak it exploded
too wounding or killing the Gunner
as Edward arrayed his forces in
preparation for the Battle of crazy in
1346 he was badly outnumbered the flower
of French chivalry took the field some 8
000 nights proudly pranced looking
disdainfully at the arrayed English
forces made up of so many commoners most
longbowmen
French were supported by genoese
crossbowmen
things did not turn out as the French
planned
we don't know exactly when the English
fired their guns that they called
cannons
One account says the English struck
Terror into the French army with five or
six pieces of Cannon it being the first
time they had seen such thundering
machines
another account writes they fired to
frighten the genuese and a third account
claimed they shot forth iron Bullets by
means of fire they made a sound like
thunder
as impressive as the guns were they did
not win the day for the English there
were too few projectiles and too little
gunpowder for reloading but they did
point to the future of warfare in which
weapon developers were more important
than highly trained and expensive
knights in shining armor in fact one
late 15th century commentator lamented
any Nave with a gun can kill a nobleman
that was the wave of the future
at the Battle of crazy Edward won the
field by another Innovation his
longbowmen the Longbow had a greater
range than the crossbow and could be
fired with unprecedented speed the guns
and longbows marked the decline of
mounted Knights as the shock troops of
medieval warfare that's easy to see
but the weapons also marked a shift from
defense to offense as the main battle
philosophy
in the Middle Ages one of the keys to
strategy was defense
armor shielding Knights while they
fought with their major weapon their
strong arms wielding swords
the defense of philosophy also gave rise
to Great castles with walls and Towers
to withstand sieges and walls around
towns to protect the inhabitants
these are the visible reminders of the
Middle Ages the remnants of walls and
defensive towers that people entrusted
with their safety
however as the Battle of crazy showed
safety for the future lay in offensive
reach of the weapons the longbowmen and
Gunners struck the Invaders before they
could come into Reach This is the future
of warfare guns to fire further than the
enemies and of course airplanes
InterContinental missiles and drones to
reach an enemy while staying Out Of
Reach
after the Middle Ages people tried to
retain old models of defense for example
building forts with sharply angled walls
to keep cannonballs from being able to
make a Direct Hit or adding sharply
angled plate armor to try to deflect
bullets
but these didn't really work
we don't build protective walls anymore
the future of warfare lay an offensive
reach striking an enemy before they can
reach you
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandria